a lot of people watch this played out
and this is my chance to find out what
was going on and tried to get on stage
that's when the Eagle at the Super Bowl
here at Super Bowl Eagles win this is a
giant night for the Eagles yeah giant
night for you your big fan you tried to
get up on stage during the trophy
presentation we have a photo here
this man is stopping it this man is
stopping you from getting up there yeah
tell us a little bit about this exchange
what's happening here well first of all
that's a that's a good man yeah okay
that God did his job he did his job yeah
they got it did his job that day because
I was a little thing called intoxicated
yeah now you know because of first of
all you know it was it was done
correctly all right I don't get that
many days off people and this was a day
off it was a historic moment I met the
game all of my friends from Philadelphia
were all in the suite my wife is there
and we are just having the best time of
our lives and you know with that with
that good time you know we're throwing
them back right so we win and something
in my head said I need to go down there
with the team one of those things you
know you get this thought and nobody
else is a part of the thought but I had
a look at my eyes that I've never had
before my wife was like what you doing
and I was like we need to go down with
the team like what I said we go on with
the team and I was like everybody let's
go I took everybody out to sweet we have
no passes we have known and there's
nothing to get us by the people that
we're getting by I'm literally walking
by people they're like excuse me sir I'm
Kevin Hart
I had so much success at getting by so
many so many people in places that I
shouldn't have been like I'm moving
gates out the way watch out so you can't
move that I'm Kevin Hart it's going way
too good we get down to the field and
we're like picking up the confetti it's
like amazing I'm like oh my god this is
history we're part of history the Eagles
first Super Bowl and we're on the field
that they did then I'm trying to like
put some turf in my pocket I'm doing
it's just bad I get another another
light bulb that goes off and I go the
city of Philadelphia want to see me hold
this trophy I mean I need to get coming
through the prices coming going with I'm
a hundred percent I'm invested I told my
wife babe you stay right here I'll be
back
I'm gonna go hold the trophy for my city
that's what I told her
she said what I said you would never
understand if we put my city it's a
totally selfless it's not for me nothing
to do with me yeah for my city right man
here's how stupid I am people I'm trying
to get to the trophy the football team
is right here I'm celebrating with the
Eagles I'm in the middle of the Eagles
huddle they're pushing me around is
great I've noticed because I watched a
video later they say they say riches
which is how you know you were at this
hour
I hear in the video you hear one of the
players go keV the trophy right here
come hold the trophy and take a picture
with the trophy
you also hear me go now I'm going up
here to take a picture with the trophy
the trophy is right here man I'm going
up here to take a picture with the
trophy
the trophy is right here I instead go
walk to the stage
keep in mind dumb Kevin this is the most
incredible moment for football in
general this is where the Commissioner
comes up he takes the trophy
he gives the trophy to the owner the
owner then says what he wants to say and
the owner then gives it to whether the
said MVP is I didn't care about none of
it I needed to get there so I could hold
the trophy and go Philadelphia I did it
[Applause]
I will tell you this I will tell you
this if I could do it all over again
I a hundred percent would do it the
exact same way I've never had a better
time in my life the right thing yeah you
know now granted you know I would I
would try to listen to my wife you know
wife's alright so yeah that's what this
boy they're not there often right that's
the one person that I can say told me no
firmly three times that night when I was
trying to do only thing that she was
wrong about is the turf that I stole you
know I got the football turf that I had
in my pocket and I framed it in this car
Kevin stupid day I don't know I gotta
get you a new email address that's what
it is I said that you called me on my
email address yeah I called you you know
you don't answer your hotmail line I
called me I have an old phone with a
crank alright yeah yeah I'm missing out
with the real fun okay no idea what I'm
like when I'm get some iced tea of me
here we go
you